Maré noire l'opération nettoyage
commence la colère des breton ne s'ap
pas Italie le PAP Paul 6 lance un appel
pour que les terroristes libèent
Aldo négociation européenne cette
semaine en ve la fixation des prises
agricoles le ti C pour gagner
aujourd'hui il fallait jouer le 13 le 3
et le
bonsoir et puis tout de suite un titre a
ajouté les inondations dans la région
parisienne où beaucoup d'habitants de
sénémarne du valdearne et de lesson
viennent de passer leur weekend les
pieds dans l'eau le loin a tenu la
vedette avec la crue la plus
spectaculaire 80 cm en une nuit
spectaculaire mais pas dramatique on a
même l'impression qu'au fil des années
les riverins s'habituent à cette
catastrophe du quotidien écoutez par
exemple cette vieille dame interrogée
par Denise
BO est-ce que vous avez envie de vous
déplacer depuis que la crue existe ici à
saintmamet est-ce que vous avez envie
d'aller à la messe ou pas du tout madame
quand il y a la crue on ne bouge pas
c'est pas un peu
monotone dans la vie il faut prendre les
circonstances faut se plier au problèmes
au difficulté de
l'existence
mais là votre cave est inondée oui les
caves sont inondé plein d'eau alors
qu'est-ce que vous pensez à sauver quand
il y a une inondation comme celleel
qu'est-ce que vous madame on touche
pas parce que précédemment nous faisions
le commerce de en gros et les bouteilles
qui s bouché ça pr dans
de plus le vin l'eau qui vient à une
propriété de glacé le vin pendant 3 mois
il fallait pas disposer des bouteilles
mais ça lui donnait un vieillissement
prématuré qui ne gâtait pas la
qualité j'ai connu la première crue
j'étais sur le C scène où il y a
maintenant la pharmacie alors à ce
moment-là c'était facile d'accès les
pompiers on avait
mis puis même ici une corde avec un
panier et on descendait le panier par
lequel on mettait le ravitaillement et
vous n'avez jamais eu envie de de
déménager oh non on nabandonne jamais
une maison qui est en cru madame à moins
que ce soit obligé qu'il y ait de l'eau
jusqu'au plafond sinon B si on a un
premier étage on habite au premier étage
pour pouvoir surveiller ce qui se passe
en
bas sans aucune commune mesure avec ces
inondations la maraine noire maintenant
après les manifestations d'hier les
Bretons ont vu arriver aujourd'hui près
de 7000 volontaires sur les côtes du
Finistère et les côtes du nord pour la
grande opération nettoyage l'espoir
peut-être même si la colère demeure
devant le désastre économique causé par
cette pollution de la mokocadis il faut
les fixer sur la pellicule ces oiseaux
de mer de la côte bretonne qui ne sont
pas encore touchés par le mazout dans 30
ans on retrouvera leurs traces dans les
cinématèques car les Bretons ne se font
plus trop d'illusion d'autres amoko
cadis viendront se jeter sur leur
côte petit port de mer de chaloupe à la
mer les flots se
retirent un ciel de mazoute au cul de ma
route mon petit
et j'en ai marre de la mer si tu savais
comme j'en ai marre entre nuage et
marébasse mon amour que le temp
pass tous trafic là c'est la course au
sous vous voyez hein l'argent l'argent
l'argent et avec ça tous les grands
malheurs se font il y a plus rien de
vivant c'est ça il y a plus rien tous il
sont sur le sable à crever tous tous les
coquillages les petits poissons le bar
le mulet qui était dans les mars là tout
ça c'est
ou fini
fini beaucoup de Bretons en ont assez
assez même de la pitié des autres ils
savent bien que dans quelques semaines
quand la marin noire ne fera plus la une
des journaux le mazout sera encore sur
leur plage cette lassitude on la sent
aussi dans l'organisation du travail
surtout quand on veut faire pointer des
volontaires oui puis ils veent nous
commander d'une de façon une chose qu'on
aime pas surt les marin c'est un oblp
mais pour les bâtons dans les roues
alors à la fin on est
dégoûté moi j'ai j'ai ramassé tout mon
Badard tenez je dis maintenant il y aura
plus de de chicane au sujet du pointage
je vous fais cadeau de du pantalon de la
veste et des bottes que vous m'avez
fourni pour les voilà et je vous fais
cadeau au Jehu du ma'oute en même temps
voilà c'est vrai la fin du
con on fait son devoir en quore on
trouve on va dire à Brest Morley Lorient
saint-briux les gens sont descendus dans
la rue pour manifester de leur côté les
médias ont fait appel aux volontaires
ils vont arriver par milliers c'est une
chose même si leur travail apparaît
parfois comme dérisoire quelques
milliers de gens qui verront sur place
les risques du progrès pourtant on ne
voudrait pas ici qu'à travers cet élan
de générosité soit passé sous silence
les véritables responsabilités ainsi les
graves lacunes du plan poulmart
d'ailleurs beaucoup de Bretons n'iront
pas ramasser le mazout des plages estim
dans cette affaire on tire un peu trop
sur la corde
sensible comment ça va être distribuer
les ZES moi je sais que ça m'intéresse
pas d'aller donner du poignant au mec
qui sur la côte de grandidrose gagne
quelques milliards dans l'année ou
quelques millions du moins dans l'année
et puis qui spaye des des emplois
saisonniers de filles qui vont bosser 3
4 mois qu'on licencie comme on veut je
crois que les problèmes sont bien plus
graves que ça que qu'une simple Mara
noire les hommes vont dans la lune les
Français envoient des plongeurs à 500 m
sous la mer mais sur 150 komè de côte
polluée on ramasse le mazout avec des
camions et surtout des pelles les
Bretons demandent qu'on s'en souvienne
le jour proche peut-être où sera lancer
un pétrolier d'un million de
tonnes autrefois dans dans en Bretagne
quand il y avait des carcasses elle avit
elles avaient au moins le mérite de pas
polluer c'était un un un paysage qui
était commun en Bretagne je crois mais
là franchement avec tous ceux que ça a
déchargé je crois que c'est un peu
lamentable parallèlement à ça on n' pas
fait de on na pas pris les dispositions
pour cette espèce de gigantisme de ce
progrès qui nous tombe sur la gueule
avec un grand pé on sait même pas d'où
ça c'est venu quoi tu comprends on nous
a même pas donné le mode d'emploi pour
ça il aura fallu quatre marin noir et 11
ans pour que des Bretons prennent
conscience de cela un peu plus de
progrès de confort cela ne veut pas
forcément dire plus de bonheur briser
sur l'écueil un Cheval d'orgueil pourit
en
silence et j'en ai marre de la mer si tu
savais comme j'en ai marre entre nuage
et Mar bass mon
amour que le temp
pense
la pollution de laamokocadis catastrophe
économique catastrophe écologique des
scientifiques d'ailleurs français et
étrangers sont en train de dresser le
bilan de cette tragédie qui touche la
faune et la flore des côtes bretonnes et
ils cherche déjà ce qu'il faudra faire
pour retrouver l'équilibre naturel de
cette région Philippe dumz a suivi leurs
travaux les premières conséquences d'une
Maré noire sont évidemment celles qu'on
aperçoit immédiatement le sable plein de
pétrole et bon nombre d'animaux marins
morts ce que l'on voit et ce que l'on ne
voit
pas et puis il y a les oiseaux avec en
plus toute la notion sentimentale qu'il
représente c'est ici sur la côte que
viennent se reproduire la plupart des
animaux marins mollusqu crustac poissons
oiseaux ici en Bretagne on appelle ça la
nurcerie et en pleine période de
reproduction on imagine assez facilement
ce que les éléments toxiques de ce
pétrole ont pu
provoquer en mer la situation n'est
guerre plus brillante en surface le
pétrole empêche les rayons du soleil de
passer il n'y a plus de photosynthèse
c'est-à-dire d'assimilation par les
plantes sous-marines de la
lumière certains prélèvements effectués
au niveau du fond montre déjà qu'une
couche nonnégligeable de pétrole s'est
déposée asphyiant tout ce qui vit dans
la vase ou dans le sable entre les deux
c'est de la vinaigrette ou du pétrole en
émulsion avec de l'eau là se situe le
zoau et le phytoplancton qui est à la
base de la nourriture des plantes et des
animaux marins si le plancton est mort
c'est tout l'équilibre dans la pyramide
de la nourriture qui posera des
problèmes et les scientifiques cherchent
à savoir à quelle sorte d'équilibre ils
ont
affaire ce qui est important c'est de
pouvoir suivre l'évolution de cette
pollution c'est-à-dire le retour à un
certain équilibre équilibre que je
définit en de trois types en quelque
sorte dans le cas le plus optimiste on
aura on sera en présence de l'équilibre
qui existait antérieurement donc c'est
la solution la plus optimiste que nous
espérons tous
euh deuxième équilibre possible c'est un
nouvel équilibre un équilibre biologique
différent de celui qui existait
auparavant et dans le cas le plus
pessimiste c'est l'équilibre fossile
c'est-à-dire la mortalité d'une
zone ici ce sont des Larbes de moules vu
au microscope après injection d'une
solution de pétrole un très grand nombre
meurt rapidement ou présente des
malformations pourtant le pétrole de
laamokocadis n'est pas des plus
toxiques d'autres essais sont
actuellement faits pour déterminer la
consommation d'oxygène de différentes
larmes quand elle est trop importante
c'est que l'animal se débat avant de
mourir presque inélectablement
en laboratoire sur des bateaux de
recherche les scientifiques après avoir
fait le bilan des dégâts espèrent bien
apporter des
solutions je vais vous donner
concrètement quelques idées que nous
avons à l'heure actuelle tout d'abord
les zones utilisées pour élever les
huîtres dans les aberères nous pouvons
bien sûr suivre la décontamination du
milieu à travers des analyses chimiques
dans l'eau et dans les sédiments mais
cela c'est une mesure instantanée à un
moment donné à une station donnée ce
n'est pas tout à fait représentatif
alors une autre technique consiste à
installer d'ici un mois 2 mois dans ces
mêmes milieux des animaux parfaitement
sains et au bout de 15 jours de voir
s'ils ont effectivement accumulé à des
teneurs inquiétantes dangereuses des
produits d'origine pétrolière voilà un
premier point un second point qui je ne
pense pas qu'il puisse être réalisé
actuellement mais qui pour l'avenir est
intéressant vous savez que le pétrole
est quelque chose de biodégradable
parfaitement utilisable par des levures
et notamment il existe des procédés
industriels qui utilisent le pétrole
comme substrat comme source de
nourriture pour des levures alors on
peut se demander si on ne pourrait pas
ensemancer notamment des plages avec les
germes les plus utiles pour dégrader ce
type particulier de pétrole et obtenir
finalement un résultat il y a eu des
essais à très petite échelle jusqu'à
présent en laboratoire les résultat ne
sont pas concluants et bon pour cette
fois-ci nous ne sommes pas prêts mais
c'est une possibilité à laquelle on peut
songer
chaque pollution pétrolière est un cas
particulier la catastrophe de porsal par
son ampleur posera de gros problème
pendant plusieurs années si les
chercheurs arrivent à régénérer
certaines zones complètement mortes ils
ne sont pas du tout sûrs de retrouver
exactement le même équilibre biologique
qu'auparavant à propos de cette Mara
noire notons pour la petite histoire
qu'un pétrolier britannique de 220000
tonnes qui ressemblait donc comme un
frère à la mokocadis a eu comme lui une
avarie de gouvernaille il s'est échoué
près de Hambourg en Allemagne fédérale
hier heureusement il n'y a pas eu de
fuite de pétrole et surtout les
puissants remorqueur qui sont tout de
suite entrés en action ont pu le dégager
cet après-midi les habitants de la
région ont tout de suite eu un petit
frisson quand même dimanche 2 avril 78
date anniversaire de la mort de Georges
Pompidou en début d'après-midi le
général van brmerche le chef de
l'état-major particulier du président de
la République a déposé une gerbe de
fleur sur la tombe de l'ancien chef de
l'État à orvillier dans les ivelines au
nom de Monsieur Valéri
giscardestin la politique était au
ralenti ce weekend à retenir tout de
même l'intervention de Pierre maois le
secrétaire national du Parti socialiste
qui participait au Club de la Presse de
Repin et on n pas manqué de l'interroger
Daniel BR sur le style nouveau des
relations entre socialistes et
communistes je pense oui bien sûr alors
il n'est pas question de rompre l'union
avec les communiste l'union de la gauche
mais il n'est pas question non plus de
la pratiquer comme avant c'est-à-dire de
s'angluer dans un PR intangible les
socialistes auront désormais leur propre
programme ils vont le mettre au point
ils auront une certaine une grande
autonomie et d'autre part le Parti
socialiste reprendra quelquesuns des
thèmes du programme commun pour ne pas
laisser à Monsieur marché le seul soin
de le défendre enfin le Parti socialiste
veut ne plus être un rassemblement de
diverses tendances d'ici à 79 il veut
être un parti homogène et puis je pense
que Pierre Mor a parlé également de
revigoré le Parti socialiste oui euh il
le revigoré et pour justement le faire
il a parlé d'un objectif prioritaire
c'est-à-dire l'implantation dans les
entreprises et là il va évidemment
rencontrer le Parti communiste et
également l'organisation de bien
meilleurs rapport avec les syndicats car
il s'est rendu compte que de ce côté-là
ça pêchait pas mal enfin en ce qui
concerne les perspectives de
1981 il a rendu hommage à Monsieur Beran
qui a-t-il dit est le meilleur
assembleur du Parti socialiste il n'est
pas du tout question qu'il prenne sa
retraite c'est grâce à lui que le Parti
socialiste a gagné trois points qu'il
s'est étendu sur le plan national et
Monsieur miteran devrait être le
prochain candidat au présidentiel en
1981 je pense que ça ça sétait dit au
séminaire de Suren cette semaine euh oui
mais ça n'a pas été dit aussi nettement
et d'autre part le fait que Monsieur
Morrois le dise ainsi au Club de la
Presse prouve qu'il y a une majorité
certaine au partis même si le CRS n'est
pas d'accord sur un certain N nombre de
points bien on a parlé de l'échec de la
gauche aussi au club oui et alors là il
y aura un rapport qui sera présenté le
29 avril à la convention du parti
socialiste mais monsieur monroi a été
extrêmement sévère pour les communistes
il a dit ils ont évolué mais pas assez
et il faut qu'ils perdent leur attitude
léniniste qui consiste à avoir une
attitude à l'extérieur et une autre plus
secrète à l'intérieur et la gauche ne
pourra gagner que s'ils font ses progrès
bien demain Daniel il y a l'élection
pour le perchoir l'élection pour la
Présidence de l'Assemblée nationale
alors il y a aussi des divergences dans
la majorité oui elles sont d'un d'une
autre nature parce qu'effectivement là
il s'agit d'un trop plein et d'une
course au fauteuil alors l'UDF jusqu'à
maintenant a été extrêmement prudente en
ce sens qu'elle a estimé que ce qui se
passait était un problème propre au RPR
elle a laissé la liberté de vote à ses
députés mais il y a quand même un point
qui sera difficile à régler parce que
pour élir ce président au fauteuil il
faut au deux premiers tours la majorité
absolu des suffrages et si au deè tour
il n'y avait pas de majorité si les deux
candidats restaient en lisse sans un
accord c'est-à-dire que celui qui a eu
le plus de voix ne resterait qu'au
second tour et bien tout simplement au
3è tour comme c'est la majorité relative
et bien monsieur morroi qui est le
candidat des socialistes pourrait très
bien passer bien merci Daniel pendant
que nous parlions je crois qu'il y a un
télégramme qui est arrivé sur le
téléspecteur oui effectivement on vient
de l' prendre à l'instant le chancelier
allemand elmou schmi et le président
Valéri GIS cardestin se sont rencontrés
tout à l'heure ils se sont rencontrés en
France à Rambouillet au Château de
Rambouillet précisément ils ont eu plus
de 3 heures d'entretien entre 16h et
19h30 alors le communiqué de la
Présidence de la République précise que
cet entretien a porté sur la situation
économique dans le monde et en Europe et
cela avant le sommet européen de
copenhag qui a lieu à la fin de la
semaine bien et oui le c'est en fait la
semaine prochaine c'est la grande
rentrée européenne 27 ministres vont se
on se retrouverit à Luxembourg avec
d'importants et d'impressionnants
dossiers sur la table la préparation
donc de ce Conseil européen qui aura
lieu vendredi et samedi prochain les
relations assez difficiles entre le
marché commun et le Japon la candidature
de la grèe le dossier sidérurgique la
pêche et puis un dossier qui touche de
très près les agriculteurs français je
veux parler de la fixation des prises
agricoles européen pour 78 79 Jean-Louis
calméan a voulu savoir avec le
témoignage d'un éleveur de Normandie ce
que demandaient exactement les
agriculteurs français Jean lev Vasseur
exploite une propriété de 92 hectares en
Normandie sur son exploitation il élève
80 vaches laitières c'est sa principale
activité mais il cultive aussi 12
hectares de blé et 6 hectares de
betterravassu tous les ans à la même
époque va dans quelques jours se décider
à Luxembourg l'avenir de son
exploitation il fait partie de cette
catégorie d'agriculteurs qui n'attendent
pas d'aide de la part des pouvoirs
publics mais plutôt une juste
rémunération de leur travail par une
politique des prises
approprié cette année la Commission
européenne propose une augmentation
moyenne de 2 % des prises agricoles mais
ce que Jean levassur ne comprend pas
c'est que ces prix ne sont fixés qu'une
fois par
an vous rendez compte une fois par an
alors que nos charges les charges de
l'agriculture pour l'alimentation des
animaux pour les semis et tout
l'ensemble les carburants et cetera ont
été investis une année d'avance et vous
me parlez de 2 % 3 % d'augmentation une
fois par an ça ne correspond pas du tout
à l'ensemble de l'évolution des prix les
salaires le SMIG augmente plusieurs fois
par an il y a des révisions de prix dans
différents domaines l'agriculture une
fois par an c'est ce n'est pas
possible sur son exploitation Jean
Levasseur emploie trois personnes à
pleintemps pour lui c'est une véritable
petite entreprise et il la gère comme
telle au moment où l'on fixe les prises
agricoles à Luxembourg Jean Levasseur
veut bien être européen mais quand il se
plonge dans ses comptes il regretteent
la différence qui existe entre les
agriculteurs français et ce de certains
pays du Marché
Commun comment vous situez-vous par
rapport aux autres agriculteurs du
marché commun et bien nous nous sitons
comme des agriculteurs qui sont très
touchés par rapport aux Allemands
notamment et hollandais aussi qui sont
eux très encouragés alors que nous nous
pouvons dire que nous sommes très
défavorisé par exemple dans le domaine
des prix de nos
produits agriculteur allemand perçoit 1
franc 23 du litre de lait quand
l'agriculteur français ne perçoit que 0
fr92 30 centimes d'écart c'est ce qui
représente le revenu finalement des
Allemands et que nous qui nous manque
complètement si on
veut comparer le prix des produits
nécessaire à l'agriculture un tracteur
par exemple de 73 chevaux coûte en
Allemagne 47500 francs alors qu'il coûte
63800 francs en France alors quels sont
les remèdes pour
pour augmenter les les prix des produits
agricoles et faire en sorte que les prix
français puissent augmenter plus que les
prix allemands par notamment la
réduction des montants compensatoires et
la réévaluation du franc vert et ça vous
pensez qu'on l'tiendra Luxembourg mais
bien sûr c'est possible comme ça s'est
déjà produit autrefois et c'est notre
ministre de l'Agriculture de s'en
défendre de toute façon une chose est
sûre cette année encore les négociations
sur les prises agricoles seront longues
difficile et les ministres de
l'Agriculture du Marché Commun peuvent
se préparer pour un nouveau
marathon l'enlèvement d'Aldo Moro le
président de la démocratie chrétienne
nouvel appel du pape Paul VI lancé au
ravisseur devant les 15000 fidèles
réunis aujourd'hui place Saint-Pierre
pour l'angélus
dominical nous n'avons encore aucun
indice particulier a dit le Pape
toutefois nous adressons aux auteurs
inconnus de cette action terrifiante un
appel intense et
pour les conjurer de libérer le
prisonnier nous ne désespérons pas et
nous prions a ajouté le PAP Paul
6 demain toujours à propos de cet
enlèvement de Monsieur Aldo Moro un
nouveau sommet des grands partis
politiques italien doit se tenir à
l'initiative du président du Conseil
monsieur andréti il s'agit de préparer
le débat qui aura lieu mardi au
Parlement à propos du terrorisme face à
cette situation certains partis
politiques italiens n'hésiteront pas
nouvelle fois a demandé le retour à la
loi et à l'ordre les parties de droite
pour ne pas les nommer or en Italie il
est bien difficile d'évoquer un
mouvement de droite sans penser à
l'histoire
récente ce film tourné à chinchita c'est
une parodie de l'époque fasciste les
figurants portent la chemise noire des
bottes et des bonnets à pompon Mussolini
est là lui aussi pas très ressemblant
même si le crâne rasé la corpulence ne
trompe pas en somme est-ce que le
fascisme qui a régné pendant 20 ans en
Italie ne serait plus qu'un vieux
souvenir
risible parmi les figurins du film La
princesse Borg les fastes d'entan se
sont envolé elle est obligée de faire la
figuration pour vivre et dans un film
qui ridiculise l'époque de sa jeunesse
le temps où l'Italie avait un
Douch monde le monde desouers le
monde les le sport la jeunesse était
toujours employée pour faire de le sport
vous savez c'était une nation qui vivait
qui qui qui il y avait des choses qui n
avait je sais je me rappelle que
n'allait pas ça qu'est-ce qui n'allait
pas en particulier on dit qu'il était
trop trop
autoritaire des dictateur ça c'est c'est
pour moi le dictateur quand il est quand
il fait bien les dictateur c'est mieux
beaucoup de têtes qui raison c'est une
qui raisonne bien pour moi mais
peut-être ça je sais pas et alors la
différence disons dans la vie toujours
quotidienne entre l'Italie d'aujourd'hui
d'Al et d'aujourd'hui et on la voit la
différence les grèves les désordres la
délinquence je sais pas comment
s'appelle la délinquence et cetera la
jeunesse qui qui veut faire de sa tête
qui n'a personne qui qui la qui la
guide négligence ou fatalisme à Rome la
pierre et le marbre rappellent encore
abondamment Mussolini en ce temps-là les
trains arrivaient à l'heure on pouvait
laisser sa bicyclette sur le trottoir il
n'y avait pas de grève pas d'attentat
combien d'Italiens se référent à
l'époque fasciste appellent de leur vœux
un régime d'ordre dans lequel la
sécurité des citoyens serait assuré
l'extrême droite en Italie n'est pas
négligeable avec une cinquantaine de
députés au Parlement on qualifie
courment ce parti de
néasciste tout on dit ào fe fciste
pasès
difficile on fait encore le salut
fasciste en Italie une minorité s on
ant terrorisme des Brigades rouges les
attentats et la criminalité galopante
pourrait bien précipiter l'instauration
d'un régime fort d'un régime de type
fasciste c'est exactement ce que veulent
les Brigades Rouges la formation d'un
état réactionnaire qui justifierait leur
combat et provoquerait peut-être la
guerre civile ce régime jouerait sur
l'écœurement et la lassitude des
Italiens devant la montée de la violence
et le sentiment général
d'insécurité cela pourrait ressembler à
de la politique fiction s'il n'y avait
pas justement le cédent du fascisme en
Italie Israël révélation étonnante du
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la kneset le Parlement
selon le professeur Arens Moché Dayan
l'actuel ministre des Affaires
étrangères aurait promis sans même
consulter le gouvernement à l'Égypte
qu'elle allait récupérer l'ensemble du
Sinaï et c'est cette promesse qui aurait
permis au président Sadat de venir en
Israël une révélation qui demande
confirmation bien entendu et qui d'ors
et déjà provoque de vif remous à
Jérusalem et cela d'autant plus que le
président Sadat dans un entretien à
l'hebdomadaire octobre a parlé de
Monsieur béin comme d'un homme politique
du vieux temps de l'ancienne garde il
est incapable de permettre d'éliminer
l'obstacle psychologique entre l'Égypte
et Israël jugement bien sévère pour
Monsieur bin qui semble maintenant
contesté également par sa propre opinion
publique à en croire la manifestation
d'hier soir à Tel
Aviv jamais les Israéliens n'avaient
lancé un tel avertissement à in ils
étaient plus de 30000 hier soir pour
dénoncer la politique du premier
ministre israélien étudiants jeunes
employés ils accusaient bin d'avoir
fermé la porte de la paix à l'Égypte
après la visite de sa dat à Jérusalem
notre sécurité n'est pas dans la
conquête des territoires disaient les
orateurs pour la plupart de jeunes
officiers de réserve qui avaient choisi
pour thème la paix dès
aujourd'hui
3 semaines après son intervention au
Liban sud l'armée israélienne campe
toujours sur place aucun retrait n'a été
amorcé avant de céder la place au casque
bleu qui continue de s'installer israël
veut être sûr qu'ils empêcheront de
nouvelles infiltrations de
fedï un nouveau contingent norvégien de
la force des Nations Unies est arrivé
par TelAviv avec armes et bagages les
soldats de l'ONU au Sud Liban
atteindront bientôt les 4000 prévu par
le Conseil de
sécurité mais le chef d'état-major de
l'armée israélienne le général Gour qui
vient d'effectuer une tournée sur le
front doute de leur capacité de
contrôler la région avez-vous des cartes
vos hommes saventil où ils sont et à qui
vous aurez affaire en souhaitant bonne
chance au casque bleu le général Gour
avait l'air sceptique sur le maintien du
cesser le feu au Sud
Liban le président libanais SIS vient de
remercier aujourd'hui par l monsieur
Valérie giscardestin pour la
participation française à la force
intérimaire des Nations Unies au Liban
c'est-à-dire tout simplement pour avoir
envoyé sur place des casques bleus la
pluie lappuie de la France est un motif
de réconfort et d'espoir a ajouté
monsieur Sarkis pour terminer ce journal
je vous rappelle qu'il y avait un tiercé
aujourd'hui à Longchamp dans la 4e
course ce tiercé cette course plutôt a
été remportée par grandmogol 13 suivi de
Silver Eagle le 3 et de barboton le 14
donc le tierc c'est 13 3 14 un tiercer
qui rapporte dans l'ordre pour 5 francs
2209 francs 50 et dans un ordre
différent 409
francs il reste à à vous donner la météo
pour demain lundi c'est assez simple le
temps restera médiocre en matinée des
Alpes à la Corse et puis une nette
amélioration va se dessiner dans
l'après-midi sur les autres régions
d'ailleurs après la dissipation des
brouillards matinaux il fera beau les
vents seront faibles les températures
plutôt fraîches le matin marqueront une
hausse sensible dans l'après-midi cette
Hervé Claude qui vous présentera la
dernière édition du Journal de ce jour
le plus court de l'année ce dimanche n'a
duré que 23h il vous donne donc
rendez-vous à 22h25 pour un panorama
complet de l'actualité je vous souhaite
une très belle soirée sur Antenne
2 ah